so you get arrested for robbing a drug
dealer but you kidnap someone during the
robbery so you get arrested for the
kidnapping now I didn't know it was
kidnapped but I thought kidnapping was I
got to bring it to my house send your
uncle a note and tell them I got you
here
what was this see the problem was there
was no Law and Order
see when Law and Order came on now I
know everything I get to do right
and I want to know that's be you I'm not
a tree jumper
going on I like to steal do drugs and
[__] whatever yeah so I know what can
happen What
so I get the boulder I'm trying to get
my life together on I join up the
classes at the University of Colorado
okay now I'm not a Colorado Mountain
College no more I'm at the University
with a GED let's go
no college no high school diploma they
were like yeah we'll give you whatever
you want I'm paying for classes they're
not even doing no background checks yeah
and one day I'm working and I'm doing
coke like
and I started selling cars I was making
great money selling cars yeah and doing
coke at night and taking two classes a
week at night
and one day I'm at the Subaru place I'm
selling Subarus like a mother and one of
the guys that got fired he got fired for
something he came back and I go what
what the [__] you bending because I got
fired and he had like a black eye and I
go what's the black guy from
and he goes huh
it's a long story I go we got nothing
but time and he goes listen to what
happened he goes I got a DUI I crash
against a tree and when they brought me
to the hospital
the pharmacy door was open so he broke
into the pharmacy he took all the
pillows and cocaine he jumped out a
window and they caught him like two days
later wow so now he's gonna do time
so he goes I'm staying with this guy and
he's got two kilos of Coke I'm gonna
steal it from him and see who can help
me sell it and then I'm gonna move to
Arizona so I have to do this time
and I'm like I'm living in Boulder
it's fun I got a nice girlfriend
you know I got a dog I got a job
but
my friends are in New York City getting
it in getting it on yeah they're coming
to the city on the weekends they're
going to hunt the mountain on the
weekends to ski and snort they were
telling me they threw a bag of coconut
on a Friday and when they came back all
the deal were dead on Sunday you know it
was like I'm out here with these [__]
yokels yeah yeah
and my friends are to lighten their
balls on fire their parents are calling
me have you heard from my son I'm like
no my friend's parents are calling me in
Colorado going I haven't seen Anthony in
a week he went out to get a pack of
cigarettes I'm like dog they're not in
the mountain get it on yeah so I was
like you know what this girl was great
but she's not gonna be my wife
I'm gonna help this dude do it as a
matter of fact I'm not even going to
help him I'm gonna Rob him you can rob
the guy who asked you yeah you're a
[__] lunatic because there was no way
he could do nothing okay so I called my
crazy friend here and he couldn't make
it out he was [__] unloading planes
somewhere in Columbia I call one of my
crazy friends here so I had to go to a
guy that I worked at the lotto body shop
before I sold cars he was like a biker
you know he had everything this is why I
don't like modern times you got
everything
he had the tattoo
the sunglasses the Harley bicycle yeah
anything to be cool
the pit bull yeah tinted windows the
loud stereo he had everything yeah to be
cool yeah and I'm like oh my God I got
to use somebody I can't take this guy
down by myself so I asked him and he had
a problem he was he used to go to strip
clubs he was in love with a stripper
right but I mean in Love With a Stripper
and she left her husband
but
she wouldn't she she danced at a nude
club
but she couldn't sleep with my friend
Steve until she got a divorce
so she wanted him to pay 20 grand for
the divorce uh so this guy wanted the
[__] so that was his motivation
in fact she moved into his house and he
had to sleep on the couch oh she slept
on the bed by herself wow she had no
intention of [__] this [__] she
just wanted that divorce she just wanted
that divorcement oh my God she's like
I'm a Catholic I can't sleep with a a
man if I'm still married and he's like
well you dance naked every night yeah
and put your [__] in people's faces
what's the [__] difference you know
wow so that was our connection so this
is the guy that you're basically
bringing on to go rob
this dude yeah
and you already know he's a goofy I knew
it was a goofy but in my cocaine mind
just what I had going on and I wanted to
believe this was gonna work yeah yeah
and then comes D-Day in fact I just got
a root canal on Saturday on the tooth
that the dentist fixed that morning
before I kidnapped him because I had a
dental appointment that morning the
dentist even said I go last time I
worked on this tube was November 1870s
like that's interesting how did you
remember that that's the dad kidnapped
the guy he just kept drilling so
went to the dentist I remember calling
them and going we'll be over there with
the money you know to buy the two kilos
from me I he was going to be my partner
he was going to I was a middle man he
was going to buy the coke from
uh Kent all right so I was the middle
man I was going to bring him over there
they're gonna sample it and then we're
gonna go back to Steve's house and Steve
was gonna give him the money and we're
gonna Rob the coke we weren't gonna Rob
give him any money we're gonna put him
on a bus to Arizona give him like 10
grand and get the [__] out oh you're
gonna give him a couple bucks yeah yeah
it wasn't going to be a complete robbery
with kicking and all that stuff it was
just going to be a Simple Thing Bella
wasn't a heavy I wasn't a heavy and
Steve wasn't heavy Steve got so greedy
he [__] it up at the intro he pulled
out the guns wow
okay so real quick break down the setup
you Steve is which one is this setup
yeah can I slip them all right guys
let's take a break for a second because
uh you got to replace your posters
look at any poster that's on your wall
it's Rip Torn tattered looks horrible
childish it's it's it is childish it is
absolutely childish and you know what
you need to grow the [__] up and this
plate is gonna help you do that okay
this plate is a one-of-a-kind metal
poster designed to capture your unique
passions it's sturdy magnet mounted and
it lasts a lifetime display allows you
to customize collect and rearrange them
at will display it also has both branded
and artistic artwork they have over one
million designs available including
official designs from Brands like Marvel
DC and the NBA plenty of video games
tons of movies and music you name it
they have it I mean look you need that
new Guardians of the Galaxy poster
obviously Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
is absolutely fantastic maybe you want
to put the [__] box in go Floyd
Mayweather on your wall all right this
plate created a unique easy safe magnet
mounting system that only takes 20
seconds no need for drilling on your
walls nothing you're renting an
apartment you don't have to worry about
repainting and losing your [__] can
deposit and all these other things yeah
just put the display posters up display
delivers its product worldwide in only
four to five business days it's a
perfect alternative for standard paper
posters that often get damaged it
doesn't leave marks on the wall so go to
display.com slash flagrant or use the
code flagrant at the checkout to get 20
off for one to two disc plates or thirty
percent off for three and more disk
plates now let's get back to the show
okay set this robbery up for us you have
to know how much time I had so I didn't
want to get into something you got all
the time yeah all David okay so you have
who's the Hell's Angel what's his name
his name was Steve
wannabe yeah okay and then who's the the
mark Kent Kent okay so you and Steve go
to meet up with Kent and then break it
down so the idea okay I go to the
dentist office this is the whole story I
go to dentist office I go home I call
Kent it was supposed to go down at one
o'clock it's about 11 o'clock now I call
Kent and he tells me uh come pick me up
so I go to his house and the weird thing
was when I went to his house I know this
was across the street from the halfway
house
there was a halfway house and bold and I
looked like well that's [__] weird he
lives across the street from the halfway
house so I went upstairs he's like you
want to do a line of coke before we go I
go yeah he goes we'll go over there I'll
give him a sample
he'll give me the money and then I'll
come back here and get the coach and
wall disperse you give him back the Coke
and with that said okay so when I'm
there he shows me
a grinder he was he was doing coke out
of a grinder the grinder was filled with
Coke and there was an ounce of coke and
a baggie in the drawer and he also
showed me where there was two grand
because I got two grand there okay so
and I go where's the Coke and he goes in
the ceiling it was one of those drop
ceilings that you slide up okay so when
I get there he shows me everything
and we do a couple of lines then I get
in the car and I drive him to where
we're like a seven minute drive
we get to the house soon as we walk in
this [__] pulls his guns out the
deal was let's get everything going when
you go back to get the code that's when
you rob us both yeah that's what I pull
up you're innocent even if you're with
him yeah I'm gonna rob you I'm gonna
smack you yeah just so he'll never say
well yeah how did he know yeah he
[__] smacked me yeah you know so I
thought I was so when I walked in they
pulled guns on both of us and then he
pulls the gun and goes Joey tie him up
and I'm like
stupid [__]
so I'm like what the [__] so now we got
this kid and the kids like Joey what the
[__] I put him in the room I [__] go
out and talk to him I go go over there I
didn't tell him what a Coke was I told
him that there was [__] over there I
wanted to see what he was going to come
back with sure enough he played into it
he came back he said there was only 200
bucks in the maple
but his mother was a big time realtor
and we were in one of her houses hold on
did everybody just get that you know
there's 2 000. he tells the what is a
guy's name Steve Steve to go about the
he doesn't tell them where the coke is
the 2000 and then the ounce he goes ah
there was only 200 so he's trying to get
over on you that son of a [__]
there was only 200 maybe like an eight
ball so I go really
so he's like what are we gonna do where
is it and I I I don't know well I'll
tell you what
I go I gotta go I go you just tried to
[__] with me no I didn't I'm telling you
there was I'm well there was more so we
got into a little argument he goes to me
if you leave I'm gonna shoot you and I
knew this guy was gonna shoot me I just
knew I go I've never been wrong with
that kind of stuff about judging a man
like that I mean if you're wrong once I
was around Savages yeah yeah I know if
this guy's this guy yeah and as I walked
the guy he don't shoot me and I go
outside and I got a gun under the
[__] my tire that I had from my Aspen
days I had a beautiful mind millimeter I
wasn't giving up
so right there I was like you know what
man I've always wanted to shoot a
[__] in the leg
like I've always wanted to shoot a
[__] in the leg like just to see
their reaction the whole thing and I was
like usually out and I was ready to
shoot and I go you know what man I'm
just gonna get the [__] out of here and
I got in the car and I went back to
vella's apartment
and I [__] kicked the door down
fellas the kid that was the mark oh
Steve
Steve was the thief
is the mark yeah so I said [__] this I'm
gonna go back and get the coke he said
he didn't get it I know exactly where
the coke was so I ran back [__]
walked past the doorman the doorman's
like hey hey I was just here I basically
went upstairs with no keys and I kicked
that [__] door down like a gorilla
and then I jumped up and I ripped that
[__] ceiling down because it was a
drop ceiling so you could just tear it
down I [__] ripped it down hearts
beating my hands are bleeding from
[__] pulling it down and uh two
bundles laying in the middle rap with
Colombian newspaper I took those
[__] and I ran the [__] out of
there and across from the halfway house
there was a newspaper thing where you
put a quarter in open and take the
newspaper out
guys look underneath whenever you see
those look underneath
in the 80s that's how we used to drop
off Coke there's a bottom compartment in
there that you never look at
so I put the kilos of coke down because
I thought the cops were on me and I
called my brother he went over there
picked up the kilos and took him to
Aspen uh I kept like maybe an ounce for
the night because I wanted to party see
what the [__] was going on
after that my eight o'clock they knock
on my door
Tidwell knocks on my door again he's got
Vel in the trunk of a car
and he goes what am I going to do with
him I go I don't know
you figure it the [__] out
not my problem anymore you tried to rob
me get the [__] out of here and he's
like I need that twenty thousand for my
girlfriend she needs a divorce and I'm
like I don't know what the [__] to tell
you he goes I got another guy there's a
guy that's got to pound the ass let's go
rob him I'm like get the [__] out of
here
I went I went to a bar I had a couple
drinks
snorted some coke and went home not
thinking anything and the next morning
I'm sleeping on the couch and the guy
knocks on my door he goes bro the
dealership is surrounded by cops
they're coming over here to get you get
the [__] out of here one of the lot guys
and I got my I didn't have a car then I
went across the street and call my
girlfriend and said listen the cops are
looking for me
as I'm across the [__] street I'm
looking at the cops
breaking into my house so I'm looking at
this [__] I'm like wow and after about
20 minutes I go holy [__] I forgot my
weed all right I'm like God damn it I
got the I forgot my [__] weed and now
they only left the cop outside in front
of my house to watch so I went back no I
went to the backyard to get because I
had some chocolate Thai weed that was
sent to me from here my friend used to
send me chocolates so while the cops are
in your [__] up there's only one cop
outside now he's just waiting for me to
come sneak into my house they're gonna
[__] out to Coke to get there
yep did you get it [__] yeah and my
lighter in the light [__] yeah
you have one of those little purple bags
you got your weed your lighter okay and
then I hit out of my uh girlfriends for
two days and I thought about it I [__]
with them a little bit the story had
come out on the paper that this guy had
gotten kidnapped and [__] but they were
still looking for another suspect on the
loose they didn't give my name so I
waited for two days I'll never forget I
went to the movie I went to the video
store and there were brand new movies
Lethal Weapon was a new release and
that was above the law
and I watch him I'm like you know what
man they got America's Most Wanted I'm
never going to get away with this so now
I was like it was Thursday and I go I
need more weed
sorry I gotta go into Boulder anyway and
get weed I might as well call these cops
and see what they're looking for me for
so I went down to Boulder I got my bag
of weed I got my two videos and there
was a Kmart and then Albertsons
and they were across the street from one
another
so I called Boulder Police from
Albertsons
are from Kmart and I'm like hey this is
Jose Diaz you guys are looking for me
and I got to put you on hold they were
tracing me
so I kept hanging up on them and they're
like going why are you hanging up I go
because I don't want to be put on hold
this is Joe Diaz I want to talk to the
detective in charge of my case they're
like we're gonna put you on hold 10
seconds and hang up then finally the
effective answer and he goes we just
want to talk to you where are you and I
go I'm at Albertsons but I was really it
came on yeah yeah yeah and he goes we
just want to talk to you
like okay I'll be at Albertsons I hung
up the phone and I went back to my car
I'm sitting there rolling the joint and
I see a SWAT truck come in God the
police and I'm like they're not looking
to talk to me they're looking to [__]
kill me and I'm like [__] this I told my
girlfriend when I saw her she goes just
turn yourself in I'm like [__] that
means I'm gonna miss the wedding
she goes what wedding I go Don Johnson
is marrying Sheena Easton tonight I'm
Miami Vice I've been waiting all year
for this [__] buddy I hate weddings
but Don Johnson's getting married to
Sheena Easton I gotta catch this tonight
oh my god listen guys am I [__] mind
this is how [__] up drugs are and my
[__] mind
I remember having her drop me off at the
police station next morning and me going
uh his 30 bucks get Chinese food I'll be
home I should be out of here by an hour
I'm just gonna walk in there and tell
these cops whatever some [__] story
and I'll be home in an hour
and I'll never forget walking upstairs
they told me to ring a bus and dad who
is it Jose Diaz
they go buzz me and they I went in dog
when I went in
[__] I was bum rushed all I had was I
had cops all over me killing the floor
get on the floor get on the floor you're
being charged with kidnapping one
kidnapping two aggravated robbery
accessory to a felony second degree
burglary and [__] crime of violence
my bail was fifty thousand [__]
dollars I'm like what
are you [__] talking and that's
why I'm like I'm doing your job
what the [__]
son they talked to me for a while they
asked me questions I'm going to say [__]
I'm like listen man he was selling
something I don't know what happened but
then I ended up let me tell you what
really happened that [__] idiot
who got caught Steve got caught with
Kent in the trunk he got caught driving
without his headlights huh what an idiot
wow that's how I got pulled that's how I
ended up in this but I learned the
lesson with a tangled web we weave when
we Tangled to the sea that this was that
all over again this was this it just
didn't stop you know and then I turned
myself in I had this [__] bail that
they thought and then a [__] Cuban
kid
was going to University of Colorado and
his car was found splattered with blood
and they looked in his police records
They looked on his records and they
realized the kid was going to Miami on
the weekends and selling Coke they found
his car with no they never found his
body again but his car was blood
splatted so they were thinking it was me
there was another guy so anybody who got
tied into a drug rip now they were
looking
there was another dude that was snorting
coke one night and he the cops knocked
on his door and jumped off the [__]
balcony and broke broke both his legs
Somebody went to Rob him he thought it
was the cops when it was really two
thieves so now they were questioning me
about that [__] it was a [__]
nightmare like one minute I was [__]
you know just in trouble for one thing
now they're looking at me and everything
else [__] 30 things and when I went
to the bail hearing they're like he's
part of a Cuban Crime oh [__]
I thought I was [__] dead Andrew
Schultz why didn't you go to Aspen why'd
you turn yourself in yeah
bro you're gonna run the rest of your
[__] life you don't want to run and
he didn't think the Chargers would be
that bad because he didn't know he
kidnapped you're gonna run the rest of
your [__] life do you have any I read
an article when I was a kid about a guy
who bit a girl at a wedding at a dance
yeah her and her boyfriend tried to beat
him up and he bit the girl and something
happened this guy lived a [__] like
that was the only he never even got a
jaywalking ticket for 40 years he went
he got a heart attack he got taken to
the hospital they fingerprinted him and
they figured that was the guy from
[__] his childhood and now the guy's
got to go to jail when he's 50 when he's
lived an exemplary life you know except
that mistake he made I didn't want that
to happen yeah you didn't want to chase
your whole life I was going to turn
myself in and just deal with it yeah now
it's to get out of there and now make
the decision um just turn yourself in
and then see what they're looking what
they're holding on to and
then you make your decision so I sat
there for a few weeks I had my
girlfriend my parents hated me
but he was a straight up Gangster the
dude but the pops her father was
lieutenant colonel in the [__] Army
and [__] career guy had ties to the CIA
didn't really like me but when I got
arrested
my girlfriend told him what happened he
goes you know what I'll go talk to him
and he came in for a guy I never thought
like me we ended up having a pretty good
conversation he asked me a few questions
and were you honest with him about very
honest because I learned early on if you
do something and somebody's looking to
help you I tell people this all the time
I love his death Andrew yeah I'll do
anything for you if you guys don't
understand what I mean by that I'll do
anything for you but do me a [__]
favor when you tell me who did it to you
make sure you don't miss a detail yeah
because you're bringing me into this web
now just don't miss a [__] detail
tell me the truth I don't give a [__]
what you did but if we're right here
we're gonna go back in there
that's the type of person I am I don't
care just don't miss I don't care if you
murder somebody so you open it up
completely to the Pops to the pops and
he was asking me questions and he was
like I'm gonna get you out of here so he
wrote some letters and within like a
week I got out my bail went from 50 000
to like three times
and then you know I started talking to
him more and more and I started getting
my life together little by little and I
got a job it hurts as a manager trainee
[__] like 40 Grand a year to start
some guy I knew hooked me up with it and
the guy liked me so much he called me
into his office one day and he goes
listen I know what you're going through
so I put a call in for you I got you a
job in Hertz in Panama
they'll change your name they'll give
you an ID and you could be a manager
down there whoa and I was like a [__]
Panama with Noriega yeah [__] yeah
and I'm like again then we're back in
the same [__] boat yeah yeah you know
someday you're gonna do well and this is
going to come back to bite you in the
[__] ass you know
and I just did everything I could to
stay out of there I got into the
University of Colorado I mean I got into
the university yeah like not like
continuing that like they told me I had
too many credits that I needed to
transfer so I I was sad because I joined
I tried to get in there as Joey Diaz but
they're like no can do but Jose if your
name was Jose Diaz we got room we'll
[__] put feathers in your [__]
every time because we ain't got enough
brothers and Cubans up in this
[__] that's why if you got a kid
that needs to go to college yeah and you
ain't got the money just having marry a
Mexican and send it to the University of
Montana
and whatever happened with Kent the guy
that got uh got tied up
the guy that got tied up I'm in close
contact with him now really yeah I
apologize to him on the podcast oh wow
15 years now for years I kept calling
them like I got his listen when I got
out of jail and I was in the halfway
house one night I went to a bar to get
some coke and the cat was there and he
goes what are you doing out and I go
okay
come on bro you got anything and he goes
yeah what do you need like a gram of
coke as he's weighing it in the bathroom
he looks at me goes the last time I sold
you Coke you kidnapped me and we're
talking I'm like Kent I'm sorry I was
having a bad day and we talked about it
I bought him a [__] drink at the bar
we chit-chatted everything was beautiful
and then I disappeared I got into comedy
or whatever
Ten Years Later he's on Facebook so I
didn't know on Facebook and I'm like hey
man how you doing you know [__] you I
realized what you did you're a scumbag
this went on for like two years and I
said [__] I'm not gonna hit him a lot
I'm just gonna hit him on the
anniversary of the arrest the kidnapping
so I'll be November 18th I would go cat
what's going on go [__] yourself because
I was going on Twitter and go 22 years
ago today I kidnapped Kent Bella he
still won't talk to me this went on for
about three years and then one time he
gave me his number and I called him and
he's like I don't know if I should talk
to you okay it was a long time ago blah
blah and I got him to agree to call into
the podcast and I apologize to him
and then after that I kept like kept I'm
gonna be in Tempe come to the show [__]
you yeah are you serious about that he
was serious so about three times into it
he actually showed up he showed up I
went to Tucson though he lives in Tucson
so I went to Tucson he came to the show
I posted it you could find it after 33
years I kidnapped this guy 33 years ago
now we're friends I send the money from
time to time he had problems with his
mom to try to take care of him with his
mom now he's moving up to uh
New Mexico Taos New Mexico so what
happened to Steve and what happened to
the two keys
the two keys I sold
Steve ended up
ratting me out
yeah I'm getting because when he got
arrested he was on Pro on parole
and he got sentenced to 10 years yeah
I got sentenced to four I was really
supposed to get sentenced to six but I
wrote so many letters my friends from
grammar school Jersey got all these
people to write letters and again if you
ever get in trouble uh if a judge has
political aspirations each of us know to
150 people when you die God forbid
they're going to get you 250 Mass cards
each of us know 250 people so if you
ever get in trouble write a letter to
the judge because that's 250 votes so
the more letters you write that judge
the more votes mean do you follow me
that's why whenever I got in trouble I
wrote a letter to the judge when I got
out of prison I wrote a letter that I
judge every month thank you for giving
me the opportunity I I'm detailing cars
I'm still broke I'm still an idiot but
I'm giving it a try you know I just got
into comedy I wrote them letters I got
into stand-up comedy I suck but I'm
gonna try it and then I went up in front
of him 10 years later for something else
and he [__] went in my direction
because I kept in touch he knew the
truth filled the relationship I built
the relationship with the guy so
whenever you get in trouble anything
like that you got to write letters to a
judge and explain your situation and
tell them what you're feeling and most
importantly tell them what your
intentions are with life
even though I was snorting coke and I
was robbing well when I got out of
prison I wasn't Robin at that you know I
already knew what level of criminal I
wanted to be in for me to stay out and
do comedy I could still be a little
criminal from time to time but there's
levels yeah like I could I could go into
uh a Kmart walk in and take like uh a
[__] those mats for your car yeah
right and you can just pick them up walk
them right to the return and go I just
my mother got me these but I got a pair
and without a receipt they give you a
hundred dollars plus tax but you can
always do that [__] yeah
on the road when I was on the road yeah
you don't have money for gas you walk
into a Kmart pick up a [__] fishing
rod and go high my mother bought me this
but I can't use it you have a receipt
not really so you know how Kmart has the
super long receipts CVS has them as well
yes so if there's ever a trash this
ain't no crackheads are brilliant so
there is a trash can right outside the
Kmart on Astor Place and Lafayette
Street in New York and the crackheads
would wait for people to leave the Kmart
with that long ass receipt they'd throw
it right in the garbage right when they
leave and they would take that receipt
and they'd look at the itemized receipt
and they walk right back in that [__]
Kmart and pick up every single item and
return turn every single item and get
the cash for it it was like they're
asking to get right I saw that on the
HBO did a good job of it it was that
okay this one too yeah
one day it was like the 29th I needed
400 bucks for rent four dollars that's
all my paid my rent in Boulder I was a
starving comic yeah that's it 1995 96
Maybe
and I see some guy pushing out lumber
I'm like uh oh it was a lawn mower okay
and one of those trucks like he had some
guy pushing him he's like what are you
gonna mow with this and sure enough I'm
hungry I need money and I see the
receipt just fly off the Box got him try
to go holy [__] I run in to the boulder
Kmart
and I go for the thing and I go excuse
me sir where's the uh c695 and he goes
we're all sold out of those I'm like
[__] yeah there's another one in
Longmont Colorado went out to Longmont
and there it was picked it up put the
receipt on it God gave me 400 plus tax
[Laughter]
I remember one Christmas I wanted to
[__]
what's that the toy chain Toys R Us they
used to give you Jeffrey money Jeffrey
money yeah I've been walking there yeah
I would walk in there and take one thing
I remember I ended up leaving there with
a bicycle for my daughter one time I
ended up I returned like a game of
Monopoly yeah and it kept going back and
returning and I had so many credits I
just like give me a bicycle and they
gave me a bicycle my daughter had a
bicycle